[Applause]
[Music]
what if I told you that the Iraq War was
perhaps the United States greatest act
of strategic stupidity in the last 30
years at least taking into account what
is called real politic think about it
for a moment what are the main threats
to Washington's interests China Russia
North Korea and Iran remember that Iran
is a regional power in the Middle East
they have almost 90 million inhabitants
and tons of Natural Resources with the
second largest natural gas reserves in
the world and the fourth largest oil
reserves in short Iran occupies a key
strategic position in the Middle East
what's more Tehran is on the verge of
developing its own atomic bomb while
having to deal with such an adversary in
this corner of the planet it turns out
the greatest wall of containment against
Iranian expansionism was none other than
Saddam Hussein
saddam's Iraq was a Savage dictatorship
yes but absolutely anti-iranian and then
the United States arrived 20 years ago
and could not think of anything better
to do than deliver Iraq on a silver
platter to Iran here you go kameni have
Adam you may think I'm exaggerating but
20 years later I assure you that this is
the way that things are now in fact I'm
sure many of you remember that when the
Iraq War started memes like this one
were passed around well strangers it may
seem this is exactly what has happened
because today there is a democracy in
Iraq so who has got control of power in
Iraqi democracy well none other than the
Shiite leaders closest to Iran what's
more do you remember quasim solimani the
commander of the kudz force well this
Iranian General was at ease in Iraq
organizing the Shiite militars operating
in the country in fact the U.S succeeded
in taking down General solomoni in
Baghdad and just to show you how things
are going the Iraqi Capital has a new
added place of interest for its tourist
Gates check this out the wreckage from
the US drone strike that killed Kasem
suleimani and Abu muddy al-mahundes in
Iraq last year is now a memorial site on
baghdad's Airport Road you have to admit
that even Turkmenistan has more taste
when it comes to making monuments but
anyway back to the point their bottom
Lane is that Iran represents a growing
threat as it gets closer and closer to
having the atomic bomb and now it is
expanding its influence over Iraq the
world's fourth largest aloe exporter and
the second largest with an OPEC however
visual politic viewers the situation
could be about to change in favor of the
United States so the question is to what
extent might Iranian influence over Iraq
dissipate what role will this gentleman
you are seeing on the screen right now
who looks more like an advert for the
Revenge of the Sith movie than an actual
Iraqi political leader play today on
visual politic we are going to answer
all of these questions but first let's
take a look at some history
[Music]
foreign
intimate enemies
there are three key ideas that I'd like
to remind you of the first one which
we've already mentioned a lot here on
visualpolitik is that within the Islamic
World there is an eternal cold war
between the two main branches of Islam
sunism and shiism the struggle between
these branches of the Muslim religion
dates back to the years 632 when it was
decided who should succeed Muhammad so
on this point don't expect any agreement
about 80 of Muslims are Sunni however
the Islamic Republic of Iran is an
entirely Shiite territory to a lesser
extent so is Iraq where Shiites make up
65 of the population as opposed to 30
Sunni and this brings us to the second
important idea Saddam Hussein's Iraq was
a country ruled by a Sunni Elite despite
the Shiite social majority for the third
idea it is better to take a look at the
map here you can see that Iraq and Iran
are two countries that besides having
very similar names are also neighbors
neighbors it needs to be said who did
not get along well at all they were at
loggerheads for decades ever since Arab
socialism took hold in Iraq and esposed
a nationalism that included territorial
claims over Iran in fact Saddam Hussein
invaded Iraq in the early 1980s then
Iran launched its counter-offensive
honor act the War lasted eight years and
served no purpose the borders did not
change both countries were ruined while
causing approximately 1 million deaths
then came the invasion of Kuwait the
Gulf War and the invasion of Iraq in
2003. it is then that our main man
begins to take Center Stage here is
muktara al-sadir
for those of you who do not know him
magpara al-sadir is a cleric and Son of
grand Ayatollah Muhammad Sadiq al-sadir
his father was an important religious
Authority for the Shiites of Iraq
condemned to belong to the most
disadvantaged social clashes during the
harsh repression exercised by the Sunni
regime of Saddam Hussein and as an
Ayatollah he preached social and
economic issues affecting people's lives
and thus also became a particular icon
for the Shiites his popularity led to
his assassination by saddam's regime in
1999.
the Shiites were the main opposition to
saddam's regime after his fall some of
their leaders cooperated with the United
States to work together in the creation
of the new Iraq this was not the case
with makatara al-sadir who is radically
opposed to the U.S occupation many
Shiites who had already been followers
of grand Ayatollah al-sadir saw his son
as a symbol of resistance to The Invader
and so al-sadir became one of the best
known leaders of the Iraqi Insurgency
with great power and influence in the
center and south of the country as well
as in Baghdad in the capital's al-zura
suburb known today as al-sadir City well
to fight against the invading troops
maktara al-sadir created a militia the
Madi Army operational between 2003 and
2008. this militia reinforced al-sadir's
status as one of the most influential
men in the new Iraq however this was not
the best way to come to power because as
I was telling you before the United
States established a democracy in Iraq
and of course in the Iraqi population
the Shiites are the majority so the
Iraqi Ayatollah Ali al-sistani called on
the various Shia parties to present a
single list for the first free elections
mukhtara al-sadir and the other Shiite
leaders agreed and the unified Iraqi
Alliance won the 2005 elections
the United Iraqi Alliance quickly
betrayed its name in 2007 the Coalition
collapsed giving rise to a new struggle
for Shiite political leadership the main
beneficiary was prime minister Nuri
al-maliki formerly in Exile in Iran from
where he had gained financial support
for the islamist opposition to Saddam
Hussein Nuri al-maliki increased his
popularities among Iraqis as prime
minister by increasing Security in the
country
bhaktara al-sadir moved pragmatically in
politics he granted or withdrew the
support of the sadris movement depending
on the influence he could gain over the
various Ministries his ideology has two
pillars Shiite religious thought and
Iraqi nationalism it has therefore
always been opposed to foreign
interference whether from the United
States or Iran U.S troops withdrew in
December 2011. however a new threat
began to spread over Iraq in 2014.
daesh the Islamic state has put the new
Iraqi state in check followers of an
extreme version of Sunni Islam they
extended the domains of their caliphate
as far as Fallujah to 69 kilometers or
42 miles from Baghdad faced with the
inability of the Iraqi Army to confront
them their various Shiite forces formed
their own palamilitary militias along
with that makatara al-sadir who
recovered his former militia the Madi
Army after three years of war they
achieved Victory despite this the Shiite
power military militias which are backed
by Iran have not been disbanded for his
part mukhtara al-sadir and marked on a
strategy of opposition to the government
which has paid off the sad risk movement
became the largest group in the Iraqi
Parliament and how did he achieve this
well we're about to see
[Music]
open sesame
thank you
Iraqi democracy is so much like Western
versions that in just a decade people
were fed up with their politicians since
2018 turnout at elections plummeted to
44 while his Rivals have fallen into
disrepute makata al-sadir has managed to
keep his faithful base and increase his
voters this has so far translated into
greater influence over Iraqi Affairs in
fact in parliamentary negotiations his
Coalition has obtained its share of jobs
in public companies to offer them to its
followers the creation of these client
holistic networks has been strengthening
and expanding his social base maktara
al-sadir has thus gone from being a
simple warlord to a Master of the
political Arts something quite
surprising considering that in the last
few years Iraq is finally giving some
good news baghdad's green zone reopens
to the public after 16 years the green
zone was the only secure area within
Baghdad itself it is where the U.S
embassy is located as well as various
government buildings throughout all
these years it has been an armored Zone
because since the U.S Invasion Iraq has
been a real Powder Keg the fact that it
is now open to the public again is the
best sign that the situation is
relatively calm and I'm thinking there a
few of you thinking but Grant what is
all this discontent about well the point
is that many Iraqis are seeing how their
rulers are more concerned about catering
to Iran's wishes than working for
national interests Iraq as an oil-rich
country however the population does not
see the benefits of their own dinosaur
juice this is evident if we take a look
at the Iraqi state budget
[Music]
Iraq's budget amounts to 90 billion
dollars looking at the dark blue you can
see how about two-thirds is swallowed up
by the salaries and pensions of public
sector workers if we add to that the
capital expenditure the truth is that a
very small part of the budget is left
for the Investments that are needed to
improve the living standards of Iraqis
precisely one sector in need of
investment is the energy sector for
example Iraq has gas reserves five times
larger than those of Oman however its
production is four times smaller its
production is so low that it barely
covers half of the country's own
consumption and the reality is even more
scandalous it turns out that Iraq is
flaring much of the natural gas coming
out of its oil wells because it does not
have the infrastructure to capture and
use that gas so who is the main
beneficiary of Iraq needing to import
gas I bet you didn't see this move
coming Iraq owes Iran 11 billion dollars
for gas Imports says Iranian Ambassador
this suits Iran just fine because U.S
sanctions prevent it from exporting its
natural resources but Washington grants
exemptions to Iraq because the country
needs Iranian gas to cover a third of
its electricity production in fact when
there are problems with Iran's gas
supply blackouts occur those of you who
have been watching visualpolitik for a
long time already know that we often
repeat that countries whose energy
Supply is not secure have a lot of
difficulties getting their economic
sectors to prosper everyone understands
this even the Iraqis who are outraged at
the rule serve Iranian interests more
than those of their own State however
this is something that is collapsing
under its own weight and not because of
a religious issue far from it
[Music]
as is obvious Iraqis were wondering what
the government is doing with the record
revenues gained in 2022 from the oil
sector 115 billion dollars to be exact
and not surprisingly when they do get
the answers it's even worse Heist of the
century how 2.5 billion dollars was
plundered from Iraqi State funds in Iraq
ghost workers are all the rage these are
workers who do not exist but they
collect their salaries in other words
the rulers have fictitiously fattened
the lists of public workers to pocket
their salaries it is estimated that 10
of public employees are ghost workers so
yes Iraq has evolved a lot it is getting
safer and there is democracy but it is a
hyper-corrupt country in any other place
people would criticize it and say hey
look what Scandal this politician is
creating he's blatantly stealing the
money but in Iraq it's not that simple
the country has oil coming out of its
ears technically its per capita income
is that of a country like Jordan however
the stand of living is not equivalent
Public Services leave a lot to be
desired and there are still even power
cuts and you'll probably say okay but is
that so important well that is exactly
what brought the Taliban back into power
in Afghanistan people were fed up with
the corruption in the state institutions
not working and the case of Iraq how
could the situation change check this
out
[Applause]
the enemy of my enemy
Iraqis already erupted against the Iraq
government in large protests during the
fall of 2019. they demanded an end to
corruption and better Public Services
they succeeded in getting the prime
minister to resign even so the
protesters were brutally repressed but
not the hands of the State security
forces rather at the hands of the Shiite
militias accountable only to Iran the
same ones who were waiting for orders
from General solomani in 2021 this
repression took its toll on
iranian-backed political parties led by
former prime minister Nuri al-maliki the
sadris movement announced that it would
seek a government that excluded all
pro-iranian factions a government by and
for Iraq it gained important allies for
this Masood barzani leader of Iraqi
Kurdistan and Muhammad al-hal-busi
leader of the Iraqi sunnis Aloha busi
himself made this statement about the
negotiations with al-sadir the time for
foreign interference in the formation of
Iraqi governments is over and today the
mountains and deserts of Iraq are moving
towards the honorable najaf for
discussions of a purely National Iraqi
government neither Eastern nor Western
Mohamed neither East nor Northwest is
al-sadir's favorite slogan to describe
how the Iraqi government should be
[Music]
an Iraqi nationalist Proclamation
equally opposed to both Iranian and U.S
interference and leaving behind Shiite
religious mandates to build a new Iraq
hand in hand with sunnis and Kurds in
the meantime however Iran did not stand
idly by Iran piles pressure on Iraq's
Kurdish and Sunni leaders to crack
sadders Alliance Iran has launched
missiles and drone attacks against Iraqi
Kurdistan likewise the Iraqi Supreme
Court banned oil exports from this
autonomous region leaving it without its
main source of income as for the sunnis
the pressure was exerted by the Shiite
militias who act violently and with
total impunity in Sunni majority areas
in an attempt to force early elections
maktara al-sadir ordered all of his
deputies to resign that is a move though
that backfired
when the representatives of the sadris
movement gone from Parliament their
seats were taken by members of the
pro-iranian parties these forces
succeeded in forming a new government
with Muhammad Shia al-sudani a former
al-malaki Minister supporters of the
sadris movement held protests in Baghdad
that led to Violent clashes with
iranian-backed Shiite militias Iraq was
on the brink of Civil War until mukhtar
al-sadir ordered it with role of his
followers
Iranian pressure also reaches the
religious Arena a central Doctrine in
Shiite Islam as the concept of marja it
means that every Shiite Muslim must have
a spiritual leader whose edicts are
unquestionably followed muktada's father
Ayatollah Muhammad al-sadir did have the
qualifications to be a spiritual leader
but muktara does not so when al-sadir's
father was assassinated the followers of
the Cyrus movement were forced to follow
another cleric and religious matters and
turned to Ayatollah al-hareri it's a
lifetime job but it seems that no longer
applies alheri retires from working as a
religious Authority and advises the
Believers to follow khamenei's Authority
in Iran no marja resigns during his
lifetime and on top of that the fact
that him being an Iraqi Ayatollah and
recognizing the religious authority of
Khamenei Iran sibling leader indicates
that Tehran influenced his decision with
the aim of reducing al-sadir's power but
this move to subdue the sadris movement
supporters has failed his followers have
remained loyal and Iraqi nationalism
which pushed political interests before
religious ones has been strengthened
clearly maktara al-sadir is not the
perfect Ally of the United States but
given what has been seen in Iraq he may
be the least bad option a stronger rack
governed by a coalition of Shiites
sunnis and Kerns to oppose Iranian
dominance would allow Washington to
divert its attention to other more
far-reaching threats such as Russia and
China that doesn't sound so bad but now
it's over to you to what extent can
there be a democratic Iraq independent
of Iranian interests do you think that
maktara al-sadir option would be
beneficial to the United States you can
leave me your answer in the comments
below and as always don't forget that we
release new videos here every week so
this is great to our channel so you
don't miss any updates if you like this
video like it so we know all the best I
hope you enjoyed the video and I'll see
you next time
[Music]